tu es une technique imparable pour
déséquilibrer son adversaire gérald hall
enseigne à ses élèves depuis 1998
aujourd'hui il fait partie des trois
professeurs yves binois être 6e dan dans
cette discipline
cette distinction il attribue à deux
ingrédients travail et passion il faut
être passionné à la base et la passe on
amène ce résultat est sans s'y attend
d'eux sans faire aucune demande tous les
grades que j'ai passé ces les
professeurs qui m'ont présenté en france
ils sont une vingtaine à avoir obtenu ce
grade
alliant technique de défense
enseignements spirituels l'aïkido est
basé principalement sur leskiw
l'objectif d amorcer l'agression sans
attaquer et être en harmonie avec son
adversaire
c'est basé uniquement par les
déplacements juste au moment où juste
j'ai toujours aimé le rôle de hockey
celui qui subit la technique qui pour
moi est un grand artiste qu'il est
dirigé par celui qui fait la technique
mais en même temps il faut qu'ils aient
vraiment qu'ils soient sur la même
longueur d'onde
des combattants en jupe une image qui a
marqué geraldo quand il a découvert
l'aïkido dans les années 70 sa passion
pour cette philosophie est né à
l'adolescence avec les films d'arts
martiaux il n'ya rien téléfilm qui
passait à la télévision je me rappelle
c'était le samedi après midi
il s'appelait kung fu avec david
carradine et c'est un film qui était
magnifique
la conception de sa philosophie quand
j'étais tout jeune a été au monastère
est ce que m pour vivait à l'instant où
qui a porté le coup fatal à son
meurtrier
amoureux du japon et des arts martiaux
geraldo s'est également lancé dans le
karaté depuis six ans mais pour lui
quelle que soit la discipline
il s'agit d'une grande et même famille